this is jaco podcast number 97 with echo
Charles and me jakka Willick good
evening echo good evening to the master
stonemason in the town of Mansfield
greetings in god much beloved parents if
my small letter finds you in good health
I should be mightily glad what concerns
me I am pretty much in health here in
the white country will have to die all
of hunger all is burnt and the Russian
army has carried off all subjects as
they had such a fear of us and there is
no food to be found because nobody is to
be found in any town whatever a house is
found it is empty and dark dear parents
I have to give news of our last battle
as we had already gone hungry for three
days and March day and night at 5 in the
morning we marched into this battle with
a cabbage stump in our stomach and we
were in in it until the evening and then
we again had nothing and could not eat
for tiredness only cannon fire from
morning to evening God has helped me out
of the third battle also without harm
though the bullets hailed down pretty
well as if one were to take peas and
throw them at someone but none got me
the whole cavalry is lost now I want to
write you about the Russian town of
misery Moscow which is seven hours walk
long and as wide and the Russians put
fire to it for four hours it burned and
then it was extinguished and we were
stationed before Moscow and I don't know
whether we are going
forward or back I don't know what to
write except that you will shortly see
many cripples without arm and leg and so
many must die pitifully of hunger and
terrible dangers Russians appear all the
time for the last battle
let's end now finally farewell and stay
healthy until we speak again many
greetings to brothers and sisters
brothers-in-law and sisters-in-law to
the bolts ins the Krogen x' and all good
friends and acquaintances and I am quite
well if only I can live farewell I
remain your faithful son until death
Johann Andreas so Napoleon who is often
praised by many including myself praised
as a military genius and he was one of
the first military leaders to
effectively utilize psychological
warfare and this included most famously
his bulletins de la Grand Army which was
sort of an update it was like a
newspaper that was sent out while the
campaign's of France or being embarked
upon and that was his media so he had
control of it and he also controlled
mail that his troops sent home and made
sure that it painted a positive picture
of what was happening downrange and that
is where that opening letter came from
it was actually excerpts of a letter but
it was confiscated by the military of
the kingdom of Westphalia which was a
vassal state under the first French
Empire which was Napoleon's Empire and
the kingdom
Westphalia which is a German piece of
land and it provided hundreds of
thousands of soldiers for the Napoleonic
Wars and when I say provided soldiers I
should say specifically conscripts which
are basically slave soldiers you have no
choice you will go and fight and over
time the West value is eventually
conquered by the Russians for a period
and then some of the confiscated letters
survived and ended up as historical
documents that explained what was
happening on the ground and that's where
that letter came from through old
Russian files where they had they had
this letter and again we make a habit of
glorifying Napoleon and I have done it
right here on this podcast which is
actually pretty substandard behavior
from me since I always try to listen to
the voice and hear the voice and
understand the viewpoint of the foot
soldier the grunt of the frontline
troops on the battlefield because that
is where the fighting takes place those
are the men that execute the plans of
the general and that is where the wars
are actually won and history as a whole
has a tendency to forget about them
because generally it's the Admirals and
the generals that write the memoirs but
in this case we are going to hear from
one of Napoleon's grunts a guy by the
name of Jacob Walter and he is a German
conscript who was fighting for France so
this is a guy grew up in Germany but
when Germany was became part of and
became a vassal state like a
subordinates
of the Empire of France then he ended up
fighting for France but even more and
you're gonna find this out quickly he
was fighting for his own survival so
let's go to this book the book is called
the Diary of a Napoleonic foot soldier
by Jacob Walter and here we go
in the year 1806 I was drafted with many
of my comrades into military service in
the conscription at that time and was
assigned to the regiment of romack in
the fall I traveled with the regiment to
Prussia in the campaign which Emperor
Napoleon with the princes then his
allies was conducting at that time
against Prussia and this is interesting
because I've talked about on this
podcast before the Battle of Jena and
what happened at the Battle of Jena and
what happened at the Battle of Jena is
that the Prussian army was defeated
pretty savagely by Napoleon's army and
that made them make some major
adjustments to the way they ran things
and that was kind of the beginning of
decentralized command from the German
perspective but this guy Walter jacob
walter was actually there now this is
what's interesting and i go take some
time to paint this picture of the way
these soldiers operated back then first
of all they marched just about
everywhere and sometimes they'd ride
horses but sometimes they but most of
the times they marched and when they
marched what they would do is just
wherever they were whatever village they
were in they would go in and get
quarters in that village they'd go and
hey we're here where we need to stay in
your house and we need to get fed and
that's what they did and people allowed
them to do it I mean a bunch of people
with guns show up in your house and say
we want food and beds you know these
people gave them what they wanted
sometimes willingly depending when they
were traveling out of their own country
so when they were in Germany there or in
their Westphalia the the locals
leaving the locals would give them hey
we'll support you military guy will
support you and then when they got into
enemy territory they would have to be
more forceful but here's how it starts
off with him marching we were given good
quarters everywhere which kept me always
healthy and cheerful in spite of the
continuous marching furthermore I was
only nineteen years old
a fact which caused me frequently to
participate in thoughtless and dangerous
enterprises I think he was getting after
it as a young 19 year old and this is
another thing that's interesting so this
guy
these conscripts they weren't they
weren't permanent soldiers they were
more like reservists where they would go
and fight and when the war was over they
go back home and continue with whatever
they're jobless and so that's what
happens to him he you know gets asked
he's only 19 years old boom you're gonna
go fight he says okay he starts going in
marching back to the book in this city
it happened in my quarter that a comrade
wanted to force the landlord to sing
however he refused to do so sitting the
whole night on a bench near the stove
weeping since this man could not sing
because of his sorrow sorrow soldier
Hummel wanted to frighten him took his
rifle cocked the hammer and shot the
bullet passed by me and another soldier
and lodged in the wall I wanted to
mention this in order to show how the
soldiers were running wild at that time
so like I said when they were in their
own country they'd get good support and
everyone would take care of him but then
the further they got into other
countries they had to use force a spy
who was in the village a spy who was a
village Smith was brought before the
guard house he had letters and orders to
tell Prussians of our strength in
manpower he was laid on a bench and
whipped by two or three corporals two
men had to hold his feet into his head
his leather breeches were stretched out
and water poured on them and then he
received about a hundred and fifty blows
at last he could no longer speak because
he was half dead after this experience
the Smith was taking to the threshing
floor and shot
blows with clubs also were heaped upon
many innocent people in this city so
these guys are things turn bad real
quick things turn bad real quick and I
can't even imagine these days where
there's a lot less accountability and
you have 19 year old soldiers coming
into towns and just basically doing
whatever they want
back to the book finally when light
fired now they're getting into a an
attack situation finally when light
firing began upon the outpost we were
commanded to attack by wading through
the rampart ditches with fan scenes with
a scenes to tread these in and to
scramble up the outworks by chopping and
shoveling when I stood in the ditch each
first soldier had to pull up the next
one with his rifle the ramparts were of
sand and everyone frequently fell back
again because of the attack of the enemy
or just because of the sliding sand yet
in that place the huge cannonballs flew
above us
thundering so violently that we would
have believed the earth would burst to
pieces when everyone was almost on top
of the earthwork the Prussians were
slaughtered with great vigor and the
rest took flight into the gate then we
too wanted to gain possession of the
Gateway in order to enter the city but
at this critical time many of these
Prussians were shot along with our men
by small and large guns and the gate was
closed since all sorts of shells and
rockets broke out of the fortress like a
cloud burst we had to take flight those
who meanwhile were scrambling up the
outworks had to jump from the fortress
into the moat along with their prisoners
and all the rest had to do likewise
during this retreat many fell on
bayonets many drowned and many of us
were also brought into the fortress as
prisoners and sent away to Danzig by sea
now it's interesting this guy the way he
writes it's very matter-of-fact as to
what happens and again this is a
relatively I'm gonna take you to through
three campaigns this is the first one
the last one is the campaign
in Russia the famous Napoleon's famous
march into Russia to try and take Russia
at and everyone knows how that story
ends it's not good but this first one is
like I said against the Prussians back
to the book one morning the Prussians
surprised the Polish camp from the sea
with their ships as it happened before
Easter the cannon fire on the poles was
so heavy that they could not withdraw
fast enough their cannonballs also
traveled more than half again as far
toward our camp as our balls did across
the water since the surrounding swamps
were frozen and the balls could roll
along on ice so fast that one ball took
off the feet and legs of ten or twelve
men frequently both feet of the same man
during this blockade the Prussians
frequently made attacks although every
time with great losses one the nightmare
that is you're standing on frozen swamps
and these cannonballs are being fired at
at a really low angle and just screaming
across the ice and taking out 10 to 12
guy's legs feet going back to the book
when I arrived in this field I hastened
to look for my brother who was in the
Lilin burg regimen here we met embraced
and greeting one another and joy filled
our hearts then he took me into his
barracks and gave me trousers shirts and
several other pieces of clothing which I
needed since as I fire as I have already
said I lost almost everything at
kohlberg so he's out there and his
brothers also out there fighting and
they happen to running into each other
from time to time back to the book while
the enemy had to defend themselves
around and in the crowded part of the
city a terrible shelling of light and
heavy artillery broke in upon us and all
of us had to abandon the positions we
had taken large mines were exploded in
the breastwork and everywhere there flew
rockets so-called pitch rings which
could be put out only with small boxes
as they fell on the grass
if anyone would or could be an onlooker
at frightful explosions he could get the
finest view at a fortress attack which
is more remarkable which is a more
remarkable sight by far than a
battlefield the bombs and grenades
criss-crossing in the air in such great
numbers all floating like balls of fire
in the air and exploding or bursting in
the air or on the ground with a small
cannon report the slow ascent of each
shell the fast descent often also a
collision of them in the air
all this is a sight of moving beauty so
you get the you get kind of a sense for
how much firepower and again you don't
really think of that very often of how
these how these battles would take place
and how much firepower there's but
there's obviously massive amounts of
rocket fire grenades cannons rifle
horrible and that's the first section
that first campaign against Prussia's a
relatively short they achieved victory
in that campaign and he goes back like I
said he goes back like a reservist to
his normal life and when he goes back to
his normal life survives that way for a
while or lives that way for a while and
then he gets recalled again going back
to the book while I was working in
various ways to at my trade after the
Prussian campaign the war with Austria
broke out in 1809 and I was called into
the garrison at Stuttgart and what this
this one is a little bit more of an
insurgency they're putting down the
Tyrolean insurgents in this battle
relatively short but here's where they
are holding up a fort basically back to
the book we fired through the loopholes
and from the wall with cannon and small
guns during the heavy shelling I shot a
man in front of the garden house as he
came in a little way forward toward the
breastwork and aimed into the loophole
but after I shot and he suddenly fell
several others
to carry off this dead man and as was
often done however the more openly it
was done the more often other men were
hit too
finally we fired with cannon throwing
projectiles into large and beautiful
garden houses setting them all in flames
on the third day the enemy could no
longer hold out because of the heavy
artillery fire and moved back into the
mountains so here's a classic lesson a
classic lesson of combat if there's a
wounded person you can't run out and get
him you have to suppress fire and that's
exactly what he's saying here he shot a
guy somebody came out to try and pull
him back he shot that guy too
somebody came out to pull them you shoot
that person too well you have to do is
suppress fire when someone gets wounded
as hard it is is to do that that's what
you have to do when you say it's hard as
it is to do that that's because what you
know Oh your friend is wounded yes you
kind of the automatic thing is to go get
a real quitting that that's exactly
right that's exactly right
it's an emotional attachment yeah it's
emotional decision that people all
people most people are tempted to make
hey echo shot I'm gonna go save him so I
run over to save you and I get shot too
and again that campaign you know you
could hear the the insurgents go back up
to the mountains and he carries on a
little bit with that but the focus that
I wanted to get to today was this
campaign in Russia so here we go back to
the book in the month of January 1812 I
was recalled to the garrison of shorn
Dorf and they know that they're going to
Russia they know that that's where
they're heading but they know it's gonna
be tough but here we go back to the book
here's here's about their attitude I and
all the soldiers were very merry always
singing and dancing especially since
throughout the entire wurtzburg country
the quarters and eating and drinking
were very good particularly because of
the largest
why of wine so that everyone had is
filled flasks voluntarily filled with
wine in his pockets with cookies at the
time of departure
moreover the beautiful villages on the
main river surrounded by vineyards fruit
trees and grain fields put everyone in a
happy mood about the middle of March the
army continued on its way through
saxe-coburg where a wooded and
mountainous region began the pine trees
were especially plentiful so I was also
thinking about this your your a
working-class guy in Germany in the
early 1800s you're working your job
day-to-day I don't know I don't know
what you do what are you you're let's
say you're a metal worker let's say
you're a stone layer a Mason of some
whatever your job is but you're working
hard you're getting your paycheck
probably not great and then all of a
sudden they say hey you want to go on a
little adventure you're gonna get to
take what you want you get to go out
you're gonna get good food you can I can
kind of sense that attitude and it's the
same thing that happens with military
guys today myself included we're you
know I'm growing up in a small town and
everyone just kind of lives and dies in
this small town and all of a sudden
there's an opportunity to go out and
just get after it and live adventure and
see the world you know they used to say
that in the Navy you know join the Navy
and see the world you know hey that
sounds cool yeah and that's kind of what
this is here especially this guy is a
veteran he's been through some Wars been
through some tough firefights and and
obviously seen some significant
casualties but at the same time he's a
veteran that he's come back so he comes
back to his you know like I said I don't
know what his civilian job was but he
was laying stones or pounding on an
anvil shaping metal or something like
that and all of a sudden hey you know
what we want you to do go out and live
in nice manners that you that you take
down or let you you in get quartered in
and they're gonna feed you great and it
continues in back to the book in the
city of Leipzig anyone could see what
was going to happen since many frenchies
as could slip through came crowding
through the gates let sick was packed
with soldiers and I was in quarters with
hundred and fifty men yet the landlord
to whom we were assigned put us all in
one building the former theater building
which was a hundred feet tall a hundred
feet long and sixty feet wide
triple rows of tables stood ready in the
hall very beautifully set and loaded
with beer brandy butter cheese and white
bread after all it sat down everybody
ate and drank while eight servants
brought in the warm meal which consisted
of white soup two kinds of meat and
several kinds of vegetables in addition
something cold was served for dessert
and drinks were served in abundance
throughout the whole afternoon we stayed
here two days until the line of March
formed by columns and the departure was
ordered so like I said living the pretty
good life back to book and then we went
further and came to first involved a
middle side city in bran burg
brennenburg district we were still very
lively in this town singing and living
cheerfully although we could imagine the
unusual campaign before us but everyone
always believes in and hopes for the
best I also looked after my Sabre
and made it very sharp at a Turner's and
tempered it in fire so that it would not
break off the march was continued to
Poland through the village of repin
where the use of German language stops
and the manners and cultures made a
strange impression it was the month of
May and the air swarmed with May bugs so
that amazingly so amazingly that it was
hard to keep your eyes open in the
evening the bugs were so very thick that
they darkened the atmosphere and
everyone was busy shaking them out of
their face and hair here it became
necessary for each person to seek and
cook his own provisions
although requisitioning was forbidden
so you weren't allowed to go out and
just take stuff still but you can see
things are starting to get leaner
however everyone still had his full
strength
and courage was still alive in every
soldier but from day-to-day privation
and hunger increased and it became
necessary for the regiment to
requisition and slaughter livestock so
that men could have some meat in
addition to the potatoes and grits which
they found here and there
bread was rare and there was nothing at
hand to buy so again you can see as they
move as they move to the east towards
Russia from Germany through Poland
there's food is becoming less and and
they had left in January if you remember
and so now it's May so the weather is
actually even though there's a lot of
bugs but the weather's it's hot which
the Russian campaign there's there's one
of the best defenses that Russia asked
me if maybe the best defense that
Russian has and that's the Russian
winter but right now it's spring that
springtime in Poland so still not that
bad yet and back to the book now the
orders now the orders led us from
foreign to Miriam pole the March went
through Seberg
the roads were sandy and dust covered
and dust covered our clothing and you're
gonna see of how very quickly things
turn before these soldiers back to the
book daily the hardships increased and
there was no hope of bread my colonel
spoke to us once and said that we could
hope for no more bread until we cross
the enemy border the most anyone might
still get was a little lean beef and
hunger made it necessary to dig up dig
up the fields for the potatoes already
sprouting which were however very sweet
and almost inedible inedible one also
heard everywhere that several men had
already shot themselves because of
hardship in particular an officer had
cut his own throat on that very same day
so again it's very interesting the way
he writes he's sort of matter-of-fact
but we've already have people that are
starving and they're starving they're
marching and it's it's bad it's bad
enough that people are killing
themselves yeah kind of seem that that
like that came out of nowhere he there
yeah and I I I skipped some pages but I
didn't get that many pages I didn't skip
that many pages it it went pretty quick
from from pretty decent living it's it's
two pages it's sorry it's three pages in
the book from pretty decent living
singing and living cheerfully to we got
officers that are cutting their own
throats yeah and this whole campaign
takes place in less than a year from
January they're back by December so and
they haven't by the way what's what's
interesting they haven't met the enemy
yet right that that's what's that's
what's one of the you know as I'm
reading this and as you listen to it you
think they haven't even met the enemy
yet they're just already already people
are dying already people are killing
themselves
yeah and I don't know how much this he
talks about this but he says because of
hardship like what just just starching
marching and starving being called being
uncomfortable privation yes suffering
yeah and and and your your light at the
end of the tunnel is combat with the
Russia and a Russian winter yeah going
back to the book we believed that the
Russians would wait oh sorry
back to the book finally we came to the
memo River where the Russian border was
we believed that the Russians would wait
on the other side of the bank and attack
but nothing happened Bonaparte fired
upon the high points held by Russians
with a few cannon and sent his cavalry
across the water
the Russians however withdrew after a
fourth after a short encounter and this
is this is is so cool to hear this
because this is the Russian defensive
tactic you hold the you don't hold the
line you hold the line of a little bit
and then you and then you retreat and
you takes you you know you you inflict
some damage on the enemy on the invaders
you inflict some damage on them and then
you retreat and then they that when the
enemy
attack when the invaders attack again
you inflict some damage and then you
retreat and you're just drawing them in
and drawing them deeper and deeper and
deeper into Russia and what they didn't
expect what they didn't expect was that
what the Russians did was very smart
when they retreated before they
retreated they destroyed everything they
burned the houses they they killed the
livestock if they couldn't take it with
them
they dug the fields up so there was no
food because that was the standard the
standard does as an army as a soldier in
this time you you lived off the land
there wasn't that you didn't need a
supply chain you just lived off the land
okay we got we'll find some bull bull
hunt some meat and that's will be our
dinner or we'll dig up some some crops
that we find and that's what we'll eat
oh and wit for shelter we don't need to
carry shelter with us we'll just stay in
the houses so the Russians very smart
they destroyed all that and the French
were not expecting this tactic and it
was very very effective back to the book
on June 25th the army went over the
bridges we now believed that once in
Russia we need do nothing but forage
which however proved to be an illusion
the town of pony mom was already
stripped before we could enter and so
were all the villages so they they
thought they might be living high on the
hog but didn't happen
back to the book here and there a hog
ran around and then was beaten to death
with clubs chopped with sabers and
stabbed with bayonets and often and
often still living it would be cut and
torn to pieces several times I succeeded
in cutting off something but I had to
chew it and heat it uncooked since my
hunger could not wait for a chance to
boil the meat the worst torture was the
March because the closed ranks forced
all to go in columns the heat and dust
flared up into our eyes as if from
smoking coal heaps the hardship was
doubled by the continual halting of
troops whenever we came to a swamp or a
narrow road often one had to stand for
half an hour then another such period
was spent catching up and
drudging away without food or water so
this is this is something that anybody
that's done any kind of forced road
march in the military can appreciate you
come to some kind of a choke point like
let's say you got people walking down a
road and there let's say ten or fifteen
guys abreast and just marching and
walking and you get to something where
it's a choke point so now all the sudden
only three it's like a traffic jam only
three people can go across this walking
bridge at a time so that means everybody
that gets there has to stop well the
people that got there first when they
get to the other side they keep that
pace going so by the time you at the end
of the tale an hour later or half an
hour later when you get across you've
got a now run to catch back up and so
it's just it's it's it's painful and of
course on top of that you had the fact
that these guys have no water or food
back to the book during the third night
a halt was made in a field which was
trampled into a swamp here we were
ordered to camp and to make fires since
then since neither village nor forest
could be seen and the rain continued
without end you can imagine in what a
half numbed condition everyone stood
there what could we do there was nothing
that we could do but stack rifles in
pyramids and keep moving in order not to
freeze so it just went in a day went
from hot and this happens out in the
desert to it it's hot and then all of a
sudden at nighttime you're freezing and
these guys they get told to build fires
well guess what there's no wood
everything had been burned they're all
they could do is stack two rifles mm-hmm
back to the book we had to march further
toward dis na where we arrived in the
middle of July the men were growing
weaker and weaker every day and the
company's smaller and smaller the March
was kept up day and night one man after
another stretched himself half dead upon
the ground most of them died a few hours
later several however suddenly fell to
the ground dead the chief cause of this
was thirst for in the most districts
there was no drinking water
there's no water fit for drinking so
that men had to drink out of ditches in
which were lying dead horses and dead
men another thing we take for granted
these days we got little pumps little
little filtration pumps you can go up to
a water with a dead horse in it and you
can filter that water out or you can put
an iodine tablet and you're gonna kill
the bacteria and it's safe to drink
these guys don't have that choice there
you gonna drink this disease-ridden
water or they're gonna die of
dehydration now they get to another
village and here we go back to the book
in another well plundered village
nothing could be found in the houses and
so urged on by our hunger we dug in the
ground here I with several others
removed a large pile of wood which had
probably just been put there we remove
this dug into the ground and found a
covered roof of planks there was an
opening under this from 10 to 12 feet
deep inside there were honey jars and
wheat covered with straw when we had all
this we opened the jars and saw a solid
white substance with the appearance of
hard wax it was so hard that one had
trouble breaking off a piece with his
saber but as soon as it was put on the
fire it all melted away - very clear
honey
now I had honey to eat for a week
although without bread so they are
occasionally finding food that is deeply
hidden there's a couple other instances
where they find food that's been hidden
by the locals but it's not enough to go
around and you can imagine how you're
feeling when your entire diet is just
jars of honey back to the book on the
morning of August 17th every regiment
was set in motion and all advanced and
columns against the Russians here every
regiment without exception was under
fire again and again the troops
attempted assaults but because of the
greater number of the Russians we were
forced back every time on this day
since their heavy artillery stood on
heights and could hit everything finally
by night we had made good our position
on the heights overlooking the city and
the battle was discontinued so they
attack again and again and again but the
enemy has the high ground so they make
no progress they take they take a little
pause for the nighttime back to the book
the nighttime lasted three hours at most
with the glow of the Sun continuing so
as soon as the day broke we marched
against the city the river was crossed
below the city the suburbs on the
northern side were stormed set on fire
and burned up my company's doctor named
stubble had his arm shot away in
crossing the stream and he died
afterward no longer could I pay
attention to my comrades then therefore
knew not in what way they perished or
were lost
everyone fired and struck at the enemy
in wild madness and no one could tell
whether he was in front in the middle or
behind the center of the army finally
while cannonballs kept on raining out of
the city we stormed it with the help of
heavy cannon most of the supporting
peers on the hi old city wall on which
the Russians were defending themselves
from the inside were partially destroyed
we broke through the gates pressed from
all sides against the city and put the
enemy to flight when I entered the city
we went toward the cloisters and
churches they had many holy images and
altars as ours do the only difference
was that there was no holy water so he
there's so much fighting going on it's
so bad he can't even keep track of who's
dying and how they're dying they don't
know where the enemy is eventually they
pound the Russian positions hard enough
with artillery that they are able to
break through and when they get in there
then they go to visit the churches and
they're hoping that they can find some
water but they the Russians even took
the holy water so there's nothing to
drink
back to the book we resorted in the
evening to the former camping ground
here one saw the wounded men being
brought together to be operated on in a
brick kiln which lay on the heights
above the city many arms and legs were
amputated and bandaged it all looked
just like a slaughterhouse on August
19th the entire army moved forward and
pursued the Russians with all speed four
or five hours farther up the river
another battle started but the enemy did
not hold out long and the March now led
towards mâche sea called the so called
holy Valley from Smolensk to mow Jacek
the war displayed its horrible work of
destruction all the roads fields and
woods lay as though sewn with people
horses wagons burned villages and cities
everything looked like the complete ruin
of all that lived in particular we saw
ten dead Russians to one of our men
although every day our numbers fell off
considerably that lion hit me pretty
hard everything looked like the complete
ruin of all that lived and he's saying
that for every one soldier that they had
lost their finding Ted ten dead Russians
and again that's another thing another
tactic of the Russians they're just
gonna draw you in and they've got people
we've got massive numbers of people and
they're willing to fight nutrition
warfare and give up their people as they
surrender to do as much damage to the
enemy as they can and what they're doing
is they're spreading out the logistics
train they've destroyed the support
mechanism that you would use by going
eating what food was in the village they
destroyed that they burned it all and so
now you're logistics train gets
completely spread out over these
horrible roads and that's how they know
that's what that's the Russian tactic
and then and then when they once they've
that they wait for winter back to the
book in such numbers were the Russians
lying around that it seemed as if they
were all dead
God how I remembered the bread and beer
which I had enjoyed at home with such an
indifferent pleasure now however I must
struggle half wild with the dead and
living how gladly I would I renounce for
my whole life the warm food so common at
home if I only did not lack good bread
and beer now I would not wish it for
more all my life but these were empty
helpless thoughts yes the fall of my
brothers and sisters so far away added
to my pain wherever I looked I saw the
soldiers with dead half desperate faces
many cried out in despair if only my
mother had not borne me some demoralized
men even cursed their parents and their
birth
[Music]
Napoleon back to the book on September
7th every Corps was assigned its place
and the signal to attack was given like
Thunderbolts the firing began both
against and from the enemy the earth was
trembling because the cannon fire and
the rain of cannonballs crossed confused
Li several entrenchments were stormed
and taken with terrible sacrifices but
the enemy did not move from their place
now the two armies moved more vigorously
against one another and the death cries
and shattering gunfire seemed a hell
nine entrenchments were stormed the
French threatened to surround the enemy
from the front and finally the enemy
gave way within a space of an hour and a
half long and wide the ground was
covered with people and animals there
were groans and whines on all sides and
[Music]
that battle right there that he's
talking about on September 7th that is
the bloodiest single-day of all the
Napoleonic Wars there's about two
hundred and fifty thousand men that
attacked and there was seventy thousand
casualties in the first day and so I
always refer to that the Battle of Somme
where there were sixty thousand
casualties in the first 24 hours and so
here we go that's that's seventy
thousand in one day back to the book we
move forward and camped by a forest on a
height facing Moscow there was a wood of
green trees here we not only had nothing
to eat but also no water to drink
because of the high campsite and the
road through the fields was still
covered with dead Russians and this this
is another interesting point that
happened in this in this battle is you
know I talked about how they destroyed
every
destroy the fields kill all the
livestock or drive them away and make
the people leave so there wasn't there's
just they're just barren wastelands also
the governor of Moscow he opened up the
prisons and let all these prisoners out
I let all these people out of prisons
just to just to add to the mayhem now
going back to the book
Napoleon refused that peace treaty
proposed to him and that's actually
that's what he says in the book and
that's actually not what happened there
was Alexander he didn't accept the peace
offering
so they got you know hey Napoleon said
well you know we made it to Moscow do
you want to have peace the guys is
negative you know Napoleon was probably
gonna try and bargain for something but
he gets told no back the book and the
army which had advanced some 30 hours
farther had that further on had to
retreat because the Russian army
stationed in Moldavia was approaching
now it was October 17th and Napoleon
held an army review and announced the
departure for October 18th early in the
morning at 3 o'clock with the warning
that whoever should delay one hour would
fall into the hands of the enemies so
now they're getting told all right you
fought hard to get here now we're gonna
retreat leaving at 3 o'clock in the
morning from Moscow the road led south
through melo and toward Kaluga here the
humanity of the commanders began to
mount sorry
here the inhumanity of the commanders
began to mount the remaining troops
weapons were inspected and many who did
not have the weapons fairly rust-free
got 12 to 20 strokes through the club
until they were near desperation
needless to say this is not good
leadership and you want you people just
you want your people to
keep their weapons squared away but if
you're actually gonna beat them and make
them less combat effective you better
find a better solution for your
situation here we go back to the book
the enemy attacked us the enemy army
behind us shattered all the army corps
leaving each of us then without his
commanding officer those who were too
weak to carry their weapons or knapsacks
threw them away and all looked like a
crowd of gypsies everything was in
confusion and during almost the whole
night the throng had to retreat to mow
jacek everyone running so as to not fall
into the hands of the enemy because of
these considerable losses cannon
munition wagons coaches and baggage
wagons by the hundreds had to be thrown
into the water and where that was
impossible all wagons were burned not
one wheel being permitted to remain
whole so now as they're retreating
they've got to they don't want to leave
this stuff behind so they're throwing it
into the rivers and setting the wagons
on fire as they're retreating in total
total disrepair and disorganization the
fighting the shrieking the firing of
large and small guns hunger and thirst
and all conceivable torments increased
the neverending confusion indeed even
the lice seemed to seek supremacy for
their number on both officers and
privates was in the thousands in these
days it snowed for the first time and
the snow remained the cold arrived at
the same time too and the freezing of
people multiplied the number of dead no
one could walk fifty paces without
seeing men stretched out half or
completely dead
[Music]
similar situation that militaries seem
to get into is lack of good winter
clothing it happens all the time and
that's what happens here these guys are
not prepared for this type of situation
they're not prepared for this cold the
distress mounted higher and higher and
horses were shot and eaten because I
could not even get a piece of meat and
my hunger came to violent I took along
the pot I carried stationed myself
beside a horse that was being shot and
caught up the blood from its breasts I
set this blood on the fire let it
coagulate and ate lumps without salt
the Russians advanced and weighted us at
Minsk everyone hastily fled cannon were
thrown into the water the hospitals were
nearly all left to the enemy and as was
commonly rumored the hospitals were set
afire and burned with their inmates all
the time the greatest misery fell upon
the poor sick who usually had to be
thrown from the wagons just to keep us
from losing the horses and wagons
entirely and who were left to freeze
left the freeze among the enemies for
whomever remained lying behind could not
hope to be rescued the March had to go
on and the striking clubbing and
skirmishing commenced so frightfully
that the cry of murder echoed all about
the Cossacks advanced upon the army from
all sides again and again people died
and sometimes froze to death these were
people who pressed toward the fire but
were seldom permitted to get there so
they died away from the fire and very
often they were even converted into
cushions in order that the living would
not have to sit in the snow
[Music]
it's this this you've got situations
where you're not only fighting against
the enemy but they're also the troops
are robbing and fighting each other and
in some cases murdering each other and
he talks about this and I'll talk about
a little bit more I kind of jumped into
them and the fires and what happened was
there's so little fuel for the fires
that they would form teams of six to
eight guys and gather up wood and then
that team would sit around the fire and
it's so cold that if you're not next to
the fire you're gonna freeze to death
but if you didn't participate in helping
to build the fire then you don't get to
sit next to the fire so if you were too
weak if you were too hungry if you were
too thirsty and you couldn't do your
carry your load and get firewood you
weren't gonna be permitted to sit next
the fire which mean you're gonna sit out
there 20 feet from the fire and you're
gonna freeze to death
back to the book in every big bivouac
soldiers who look like specters crept
around at night the color of their faces
their husky breathing and their dull
muttering were horribly evident for
wherever they went they remained
hopeless and no one allowed these shades
of death to drag themselves to the fire
usually six eight or ten of us had to
combine to build a fire since no other
wood was to be had except rafter pieces
from burned houses or trees lying around
shattered wagons etc and without the
cooperation of the men nothing could be
accomplished neither did we dare to fall
asleep at the fire at the same time
because no one was safe from stealing
and robbery
officers were beaten away from the fire
just as privates were whenever they
tried to press forward without merited
claim only mutual support still procured
true friendship so they didn't care
anymore
you're an officer doesn't matter if you
didn't put out and build this fire
you're not going to get close to it
and I mentioned very quickly lice and he
at one point he hooks up with a major
and they kind of become swim buddies
trying to work together and here we go
to the book we came to a lumberyard and
built a fire there when the major had
become somewhat warm his subjects and by
subjects he's referring to lice plagued
him with unusual wickedness and for this
reason he asked me to kill the
tormentors in his shirt-collar
I did it but when I had opened his
collar his raw flesh showed forth where
the greedy beasts had gnawed in I had to
turn my eyes away with abhorrent and
reassure the master that I saw nothing
telling him that my eyes hurt so much
from the smoke that I could not see
anything these pests however were no
less to be found on me
thousands of them however because of my
constant restlessness they could not get
to the point of forcing me to treat them
with flesh so the lice is actually
eating his friend the major and lice are
no joke it's like body lice
yeah body lice yeah body lice like what
kids get you like what your kids get
from school I don't know if your
daughter's had it yet but she will
well I remember back when we were in
school would be like in your hair yeah
sure for sure that's where it starts I
don't think I've ever seen or I mean
I've heard of it yeah
and actually I I read that section to my
wife because my wife like all moms
absolutely despises lice yeah cuz when
they come home from school it's just
total nightmare you got a deal
everything's gotta get squashed and my
daughter's all had crazy long thick hair
and so it would be hours of picking
through that hair trying to get the lice
out when when that would break out but
you know that's the thing is you
have the treatment yeah right shampoo
your shampoo you have you you clean your
clothing and so it's gone but what
happens if you don't do that what
happens if they don't have any shampoo
what if what happens if you have to wear
the same clothes over and over and over
and over again and by the way you can't
take the clothes even off because you're
freeze to death so what happens you got
a nice little home for the lice and they
start to eat eat you yes and also and so
this whole time obviously they're
retreating they've been defeated and
they were retreating this whole time and
they're still being attacked they're
still being attacked by the Russians
back to the book the Russians pressed
nearer and nearer from every side and
the murdering and tormenting seemed
about to annihilate everyone that day we
expected that everyone must be captured
killed or thrown into the water everyone
thought that his last hour had come and
everyone was expecting it and so they
they're they're kind of trapped and he
that's what he's saying he's expecting
that everyone's dead we're all gonna die
or get thrown in the water and they get
to a bridge and there's actually two
bridges one of them gets destroyed and
now there's all these guys trying to get
across one bridge to get to safety
they're being attacked back to the book
everyone crowded together into a solid
mass and nowhere could one see a way out
or a means of rescue from morning till
night
we stood unprotected from cannonballs
and grenades which the Russians hurled
at us
from two sides at each blow from three
to five men were struck to the ground
and yet no one was able to move a step
to get out of the path of the
cannonballs only by filling up of the
space where a cannonball made room could
one make a little progress forward I
think that has to be one of the most
insane situations that I've ever heard
of you're standing in a mass of people
hundreds and hundreds of people trying
to get across a bridge it's very slow
movement you have nowhere to hide
and there's cannonballs from two sides
that are ripping through the people and
the only progress you make is by
stepping on and filling the holes of
where these men have gone to the ground
and died and by the way you're starving
thirsty covered in lice yeah freezing
and this is always encouraging back to
the book more over here in this region
Napoleon had left us and fled with the
fresh reserve troops hurrying home ahead
of the army the general cry was saved
himself who can sew again myself
included we do a lot to glorify Napoleon
but here he is his men are trapped and a
fresh group of reserves show up and he
hightails it out of there with the fresh
reserves he eventually gets across that
bridge and now they're just they're just
every man for himself but it's not
really every man for himself because
they got a link-up with a couple other
people to support each other to protect
each other because it is it's just chaos
back to the book it had been the fate of
many hundreds when they sat down because
of weakness or necessity that their
clothing had been brutally torn from
them and when they could not defend
themselves they froze to death naked so
now you got the choice you know oh I see
you you got to stop either you're tired
or you're weak or maybe you just got to
stop and go to the bathroom well I see
you with you're in a compromised state
and I come over and just take your
clothes from you rip him off you cry cuz
I want to be warm and it's you or me and
that's his own team that's his own team
his own team right there
and it just again obviously like I
always have to do with these books I
mean it goes on and on and on and on
brutal brutal back to the book by the
end of December we reach the Polish
border along the memo River now I was
free and left to myself again as soon as
I notice a trail
I rode as fast as I could and so now
he's got a horse one day along the road
I came to a nobleman nobleman's manor
house at which I asked for bread and
obtained not only bread but also butter
and brandy for there was a servant there
who could speak German and and so that's
it I mean almost as quickly as it all
started once he gets back to Poland he
gets a horse and he rides until he finds
a nice manor house and also it's not
really a concentration of troops anymore
that are showing up in these towns
now it's small groups it's not like
thousands of soldiers are coming in that
need to be fed it's dozens at a time and
so there's actually the food and and
necessary means to support small numbers
of soldiers that are coming in and so
it's I don't want to say it's
anticlimactic but it is a little bit
because once he gets back to Poland and
gets a horse it's like it's over and he
gets oh escapes from all that pain and
misery eventually gets to another town I
came to Orton's burg and for the first
time was given regular quarters it was
just Christmas Eve a date I would not
have known if I had not learned it from
the landlord here I also washed myself
for the first time but I could not rid
myself of the lice we met a column of
Bavarians who were on route from
Konigsberg to the gathering place at
Plock they told us the news that they'll
wuertenberg errs - were gathering in
thorn and that the Germans all had
permission to go home
hence I was one of the last to come to
thorn the same night I lodged in a house
and bought some bread and wine for free
quarters were not to be thought of one
could scarcely creep along the streets
on account of the throngs of people
early in the morning I traveled across
the bridge and saw with astonishment
that the city during this year of war
had been developed into an important
fortress however they had used only
wooden walls and sand around the high
walls I now grew weaker and weaker and
only with great exertion that I reach
the city here I reached the third convoy
of our people and presented myself
immediately to the commander who asked
where are you from from the Army was my
answer so you are also one of those
Moscow bums he retorted
and that was my welcome return
one of those Moscow bombs so just to
explain what those Moscow bombs were
they started with 685 thousand men and
had over 400,000 killed
that's almost 60% killed and I think
what's what what this book gives me is
such a classic examples really of not
only how to act but also how not to act
mmm so for one from a leadership
perspective keep your people informed of
what is happening and that's one thing
that struck me about this book often
times these guys had no idea what was
happening what was going on what was the
next move they they did not know what
was happening another thing and this is
clearly a lesson that we talk about all
the time is is you got to be humble
because from Napoleon's perspective he
thought he could pull this off right but
he under met underestimated Russia
strength he underestimated the time it
would take he underestimated the
readiness of his own troops he
underestimated their strategy
so again lesson learned for the
millionth time be humble and then
getting to this this is just that
closing statement about Moscow bombs I
think that is a great reminder to treat
people with respect and we talked about
this I think it was the last podcast or
maybe the podcast before that doesn't
mean you have to respect people because
if you don't know them you can't just
give away respect but you treat people
with respect because
you don't know what they've been through
you don't know what struggles they've
seen how would you know that
and so when you throw out things like
Moscow bum and you don't know that this
is a guy that's been actually through
hell don't do that and the last thing
you know again to take away from this
book for me is to remember you know not
just you in the business world of course
remember your front line people remember
what grind they're going through
remember what it feels like to them to
be out on the job site or in the factory
or on the front line doing sales
remember what that is but also for
everyone
remember the actual frontline troops the
suffering of the fear the discomfort the
cold and the wet and the hunger remember
that reality of war and remember that it
impacts those young soldiers and those
young Marines remember them because it's
really really easy to forget
[Music]
so
I think that's all I've got from the
diary of a Napoleonic foot soldier
pretty epic read to hear that side of it
yeah totally different from sitting here
and reading Napoleon's Maxim's
yes about his wonderful brilliance yeah
yeah bailing on bailing on his guys Oh
fresh reserves are here cool I'm gonna
use them to get out of here yeah yeah
and you know I get it I was just reading
another book I can't record think of it
off the top of my head but it was it was
talking about you know as a leader
you're supposed to stay alive right like
you can't take unnecessary risks as a
leader you're you you can't be at the
front of the assault you shouldn't be
sometimes you have to be but you need to
stay alive yeah and so maybe you could
give Napoleon a little credit there for
that but maybe not maybe not too much
yeah this one time on Seinfeld where
George do you really in a way because it
sounds dumb but this that just what you
said right then this because this seemed
what like this seems like what Napoleon
was like Seinfeld Seinfeld the [__]
George this was real real this guy a
fire breaks out and he pushes over an
old lady some kids you know take to
escape this gave the fire ring so every
went after the fire the fire
there was no fire it was just some burnt
like burgers or something so they're
questioning him and he's like and that's
what he says kind of what you just said
there he's like I had to lead these
people to safety and if you know all is
lost if the leader dies kind of thing
that's what he was saying he was looking
like we saw what you did you know you
stepped on the old lady going out kind
of thing so he kind of he's kind of that
deal I think that's what Napoleon did
yeah I would tend to agree with you and
it's you know and then in the Navy
the the captain of the ship goes down
with the ship right that's like the
least at least he's the last guy off
yeah at least at a bare minimum he's the
last guy off but oftentimes it goes down
with the ship because he's trying to
fight it and save it the whole time yeah
yeah that's the time revealed nothing
carry that out but no he came back from
this and got exiled and everything was
you know his life was ruined but you'd
sound like he ruined oh hell a lot more
lives than just his own with this
experience yeah interesting huh he kept
mentioning the lice you know yes that's
good when they do that because it really
does give you a feel of like you know
you know a little thing yeah that no big
deal yeah but it's okay there boom boom
or the hunger or the cold one it's just
constantly there because you don't
really think of that you know you think
of the fire fight and the bombs and the
you know those big things you know all
those little things adding up is yeah
because the lice are constant just
constantly eating you is that what life
does eat yeah I guess so I don't know
too much about lice I just know that my
wife freaks out when they come in the
house yeah which one you got for kids
yeah well there was times where we just
had you know a lice epidemic in the
house I'd come home and it looked like
ghostbusters showed up and were securing
the Frog quarantine yeah quarantine but
you didn't have that opportunity for
these guys yeah you pick up some of that
stuff in all these books what those
soldiers are suffering through yeah you
know whether it's job you know jungle
foot foot rot trench foot yeah you just
your feet are getting destroyed by the
weather you know you get the sores on
your back to just all these things all
those things like Travis Mills remember
he was talking about how the salt stuff
on oh yeah her back or whatever the salt
crystals forming is a no one told me
about that and I heard you know a lot of
my friends have been to come no one
talks about that stuff you know they
were hot he's sweaty for a long period
of time with no showers yeah so it's
just and humans don't humans aren't you
you're not used to that you're not used
to the people are used to that we're
used to shower
yeah you know hell yeah fresh Moroso
times a day yeah if you're training it
but you you can't get used to its like
your feet right you know some people are
barefoot all the time like my son yeah
they're for a long time he can sprint on
jagged rocks with no effect yeah didn't
even notice it
it's like Tarzan thought is dong Khoi
yeah with me I'm all sensitive you know
the feet cuz I got no shoes I try and
try and harden them up when I can but
when I slay they have been on the road
too much my feet are weak weak makes me
angry when I see my son sprinting across
jagged rocks as if it's nothing
yep tougher than you but yeah that makes
me mad I can't even fake it either
no know what I mean you try and act all
tough when you're walking yeah try and
act like it's not hurting yeah what
hurts yeah yeah I had that to eat when I
moved here from Kauai I had that where
we're all tough cuz yeah you go barefoot
when you wear slippers all the time you
go barefoot everybody slippers are
different bro for those either don't
know Hawaiian blue slippers are
flip-flops but flip-flop I wear
flip-flops all the time too yeah it's
totally different right but you know
take him off all the time no so it
here's to give you an idea of how common
being barefoot is on in elementary
school I went to school with no shoes on
before and no one said anything and if
you go to school issues on you take him
off immediately cuz you go run around
and recess and stuff like that you don't
ya don't ever tell you that story about
my son
mm-hm so my son was home-schooled for a
while sure and when he was home-schooled
he was he would surf a lot even by even
by his standards my standards but one
time he cut his foot on the reef mm-hmm
and he came up to the house and my wife
says you know hey go clean that out put
a bandaid on I put on some socks and
shoes mm-hm and he says no my wife says
what he says no she says hey go clean
that out put a bandaid on it and put on
some socks and shoes now although I was
gonna get dirty he said no she says hey
go
and put a bandaid on that clean it off
put a bandaid on it put on socks and
shoes and he says I can't she says why
not he said I don't have any shoes so it
had been since he was home-schooled it'd
been a really long time and since he had
had to wear shoes yeah and so the he had
outgrown his shoes so it had been months
since he had had shoes no need to buy oh
yeah don't need those things why you
know those things so so yeah after that
it was we I did I when I got home I had
she says hey go take him to get shoes I
said why does he need shoes because he
cut his foot on the reef
okay well wanted to get him shoes but
yeah so same thing as you barefoot
just he was just barefoot a long time
and he stood there for a lot of done
yeah both feet are tough yeah so in feet
and then now you know you come to the
mainland where you were shoes all the
time and we don't wear shoes in the
house um you know Hawaii that's a thing
and so still you know but if you have
like a carpet or something like that
speak it's off yeah bummer well remember
those little things that people out on
the front lines are are putting up with
and suffering through on a daily basis
yeah kind of seems like that book
escalated quickly with the heart yeah it
did and I think it caught everyone off
guard yeah again I like to try and think
about the guy the guys back then and
they're thinking oh cool you know I'm
working at my whatever crappy job I have
and then all of a sudden Adventure Time
yeah and good food time why and get
treated like a long time yeah and and
then they roll into the Russian campaign
it's no not so much it's actually the
exact opposite yeah one second year
eating bread and butter and wine with it
brandy brandy Bowl wine cheese and then
the next minute you're killing your
friend for his clothes yeah you can't
live yeah I didn't cover some of those
sections where he's getting robbed
they're gonna kill him I mean he's own
guys yeah you know or different there's
another little you know because it's
French
soldiers and there's some German
soldiers that are on the same side but
what do you think happens when things go
crazy all this and they start forming
their own the gangs right yeah they're
gonna stick together yeah horrible
horrible well speaking of crappy jobs
yeah maybe you could do a crappy job of
telling us how we could support this
podcast actually I'd prefer if you did a
good job I want to try to do my best
Oh back to that way you were just saying
the you know you form into little gangs
yeah in times of did that happen in why
- no no I'm gonna say in anyway no
there's this movie it's called the
divide I think it's called the divide
I'm pretty sure it's like this weird
movie and some apocalyptic thing happens
in the beginning and everyone like
Reacher in this apartment building
retreats to the basement where the
superintendent or somebody lives and
this guy is uh he's like one of these
doomsday prepper type meetings you know
the end and I think heathenism make a
manual or something you wrote a man I
know so they uh but it's everybody it's
like you know a pretty girl with her
daughter you know some dudes some you
know I got a broad cross-section of
society right I don't haven't seen the
movie but I know the problem you check
but that's what that's essentially what
the movie is about right there where
everyone's just we're all just people
right we all live in this building we're
all kind of and then they start to just
divide into teams and groups and they
fight and and the harder stuff gets the
more violent they get they end up like
killing each other and all these ways
like certain people have certain assets
so they can offer like value to this
group you know kind of thing and it's
all within who becomes the dominant
group the dominant evil group is is
these just to friend guys the person who
lives is just the one girl only one girl
lives yeah everyone else dies in one way
or another yeah it's it's a weird
spoiler alert but yeah
it's weird because you don't know like
who caused the bomb you know it although
there's a grandpa by Cormac McCarthy
called the road this is a book it's not
a move well there actually there is a
movie yeah but you don't know what
happened there either just everything is
different now and it's different in grey
and dark and everything's dead here's
like nothing living you know plants are
living nothing is living and there's
humans kind of wandering and and trying
to trying to survive it's a great book
well yeah but yeah that's the the movie
essentially they just kind of omit all
these details like that doesn't make
sense that's why the movies weird but
when you think about it that's what the
movies about
we should put Cormac McCarthy the road
on the website for people to get along
with the diary of Napoleonic footsoldier
so people can get this this would be a
hard one to get I don't know it's a rare
book I don't even know where I got it
from yeah yeah either somebody mailed it
to me which I appreciate if it was you
let me know or I just had it I don't
know I don't know where it came from my
books are out of control right now yeah
yeah it's good manual collection yeah
it's not too little anymore
cool well support I'll try my best here
to not do a crappy job to not do a
crappy job so poor Jim talk about origin
origin main comm that's where he can go
for all the cool origins stuff supplier
of yes Jocko has supplements Jocko
supplements krill oil joint warfare -
very good
essential I would say essential yeah
like if you're working out and stuff
actually somebody asked me yesterday
which someone said hey on a budget got
sore joints krill oil or joint warfare
that's a hard question that might be the
hardest question I've gotten on the
podcast yeah because I honestly I take
them both all the time so I don't know
which one it is the benevolent a better
one yeah I do know what I recommended
though I said general Morpher yeah
because I know the joint warfare I have
noticed specifically my shoulders jacked
up and
the joint warfare it was like healing so
with that I said hey go to the joint
warfare yeah at least to start with if
you can't get both yeah for sure
and I I would say I could I couldn't do
muscle ups for like six months
Oh cuz you're sure yeah yeah that's
jacked up man yeah and you know me I
don't even say anything I just work
around it like for a while I couldn't do
any kipping pull-ups I can only do dead
hang pull ups well that was the same as
my shoulder there's my shoulder I
couldn't what I don't know why and you
know I would go see sometimes I go see
physical therapists and I try and
explain to him what's going on and they
they try and overlay there they're there
they try to overlay their vision of my
problem onto me
yeah faith look for another it makes no
sense that kipping pull-ups would hurt
but dead hang pull ups wouldn't right
why does that make sense yeah that's
what happened I could do ring dips but I
couldn't do ring muscle ups I couldn't
do them because it was injured so you
know and I all I do is I modify the
workout as best I can you know not for a
while I was the only doing dead hang
pull ups and so I would do weird things
I do dead hang all different grip
pull-ups I'd do dead hang weighted
pull-ups I did all kinds of different
things to get through it
but I still like to do kipping pull-ups
and eventually now I can do muscle ups
again and I can it's it was hurt for
that's it's hurt for it was hurt for
about six months but I've been back in
the game now for I don't know how'd you
do it how did I do what the shoulder
yeah no idea oh it's like general use
general usage that's Greg was Greg hurt
his back messed it yeah no I know I saw
him yesterday you know how he did it yep
opening the window in his bed from his
bed and his wife locked the window was
laughing and I think he thought he might
have thought I was like laughing at him
like oh you're getting all kind of thing
but I was laughing at that I'm laughing
at just the idea of injuring your back
really bad by laying in bed yeah opening
a window that's that's like people
telling you get after it if you weren't
in bed and you know he was trying to get
cool air in right
- hot so he's trying to get more comfort
yeah more comfort than laying in bed
it's I I don't even want to I'm gonna
knock on wood cuz I I don't I don't even
say anything when someone gets injured
man I hate it because I hate being
injured that's the weird thing too is
when you get injured you think that
injury it seems like the injury is gonna
last forever I always have that feeling
like this is just never gonna go away
well cuz you don't notice these
incremental little things but when you
get injured if you remember the fact
that there's tiny tiny incremental
progress being made and you keep working
and keep doing it eventually it's gonna
heal and you'll be joyous again yeah
you'll be joyous again appreciate that -
you know like when you're out and you're
like that day when I was fully not
injured yeah I just chose to not go
train or not but then when you're
injured you're like oh I'm like yeah you
do what you can people ask me that all
the time honey what are you doing you
get injured do what you can't do it you
can't that's what I did like I couldn't
do muscle ups okay cool I would do ring
dips I would do other I'll do every
other exercise around muscle ups except
for muscle ups themselves because I
couldn't do them at that time yeah now
I'm back in the game kipping pull-ups
are back there got the jack joint
warfare get it yeah and krill oil and
telling you I think I think you should
do both that's what that's what my
opinion is and that started for me years
ago when I went on krill oil and
glucosamine chondroitin right now of
course we have it in the glorious super
krill warfare yeah and you're supporting
the podcast which is good yeah that's
good get that for your joints also geez
and rash guards a lot of times people
when they start jujitsu and this
actually this this was going on since
the beginning you'd be like what guiche
it I guess yeah and let's say at the
time I was like okay and actually origin
was one of them but I didn't know as
much about ordinary I was like yeah
they're cool
and then the one I saw was like kinda
expensive so I was like yeah urgent
school if you want the high-end one and
stuff like that and it was
but origin has all levels no actually
not true they don't have all levels if
you want to get a $28 key no okay now
can you can't get a level key yeah you
can get medium or awesome yeah so okay
the good point the medium is because the
first key I ever bought was $40 yeah see
I have never been lasted three weeks I
bought one for $99 and it was yeah it
was really really bad yeah and I don't
even know the brand I know if it had a
brand but yeah it shrunk to the point
where it like it fit normal and it
shrunk all almost up to my elbow just by
the way yeah and so to me if the next
one I want to say was like hundred
twenty it was like a red or one of these
brands I don't know yet and it was fine
oh I know the brand I'm not gonna say it
to hate on it but it to me it's shrunken
yeah that cool nonetheless now that I
have or origin you have two of them by
the way they are way better and I'm not
I know just that you're looking at me
like it just sounds like oh my god this
is way better the thing is it is no they
straight-up way better yeah and they
have different kinds of leaves or
whatever but they have the and really
the point there is when people ask me
and if you're wondering what key to get
go on go on the website and you can see
whichever you don't like if you if
you're like hey I want the Cadillac one
which I recommend by the way because
it's extra dope or or you know you just
want the regular one they're all good
quality all made in America too by the
way and rash guards rash guards yeah
Pete just sent me three rest
american-made American hands but when
did he send you the other one he didn't
send it to you which one does it has
I'll give you him it says it's got the
chemical formulation for Saudia on it do
you have that one okay you'll see it but
yeah some good rash cards and they fit
good too
so and again I'm not gonna say the brand
name but this is a very good kind of
high-end combat sports brand rash guards
geese I'm gonna see the name because it
is
because it's a matter of opinion anyway
so I'm gonna influence that way but I
got some rash guards and I was like cool
they look dope and I'm like cool but you
put it on and it's they just didn't work
out no I can't wear this because just
how it fits and stuff like that was it
baggy it was baggy you know I was
actually trying to make a joke yeah
cause like if you have a baggy rash
guard dude you need to start jacking
some steam yeah and Hugh started I
danced a lot to hit your rash guards
baggy I agree with that but it was weird
because it was baggy in certain areas
you know that's weird I don't know
either way or didn't mean calm it's some
cool stuff also it's made in America no
big deal yeah from beginning to end yeah
just funny you just said the whole thing
but the actual one of the best things
about origins made America that's yeah
that's awesome in my opinion yeah with
American hands well then again I don't
know think about this what if it's all
made in America was you know then legit
from from the cotton grown all the way
to the end product but when you get it
the rash guard fits all back in certain
areas I don't know kind of defeats the
purpose really well yeah look what
happened to cars in America in the 80s
right people started buying Japanese
cars because the American quality they
wanted by America but the American
quality wasn't there yeah now yeah but
at that time period yeah your your rear
view mirror was gonna fall out yeah it's
kind of like you know I don't know if
you ever had a had a friend or something
or maybe yourself you start like a
clothing brand right I remember back
when I first started to like everyone
that was kind of like the thing start a
clothing brand starts jiu-jitsu month
three start a clothing brand yeah that
was kind of like the joke you know and
so a lot of people they not a lot of
people but some people they here you
know then you that that's kind of the
the textbook process you start your
brand you give away write your stuff to
key people and you know hopefully it
kind of takes holding takes off so
sometimes I get the shirt and the
designs are cool for the time they were
cool but then when you put on the shirt
it doesn't like fit character you know
cuz when they got the blanks yeah
they just were like hey I got a cut
across hey this is a blank black shirt
yeah you know what's the difference kind
of thing but the hint thing is there is
a difference the end when you put it on
bra the design can see outstanding but
if no one's gonna wear it who cares so
who knows check but it is a big deal
made in America from the cotton all the
way to the end product that is a big
deal and that's on top of the fact that
the product is perfection concur also
speaking of fitness being fit were we
talking about being fit not really but
you go with it yeah yes oh yes we were a
muscle ups and joint worker though yeah
yeah
so kettlebells I'm into I think this is
just me because I'm spoiled
but the kettlebells from on it and you
know there's like copycat brands you
know they do that I'm nothing with
kettlebells specific copycat artistic
Nobel so here's the things I don't see
them I don't know if there's there
specifically copycat because there's
other ones yeah for sure there was like
a skull one and like this this other
ones but if my head was a kettlebell how
much would it weigh that's like dumb a
be like it's dumped over 103 yeah it's
like 200 something bad oh that's big
yeah go on someone sent it to me on
Twitter oh I thought they sent it to you
in real life I'm gonna take it from your
house you know I might like when you
know okay so what how I did it was I got
the the chimp right it's like 35 pounds
or something like that
so I get two of them and that's when I
started kettlebells so they're like
start start lighter like this so maybe
like 35 dude yeah whatever
wait is that too late she's not light
enough not too right whoa
when I started I was like this is
appropriate I got to be careful union
with this cuz I had never really done it
I picked it up and you know so staying
safe and I was like cool
formulating a good workout now somebody
get the bigger ones right so I went up
to you there out of the one I wanted so
I went all the way up to the world wolf
which is like 62 pounds that's good so
start doing that with that got good at
that boom boom so but keep in mind I'm
getting them from on it like I I don't I
I have the luxury of getting like the
good ones you know I'm all spoiled so
I'm over here like I'm about to say
everyone should have the design one
because it's like cooler and I don't
know you get tenem you know how like
when you get like a new cool rash guard
right something with a cool design on it
you want to wear it and use it you know
you know I'm saying instead of that you
get that get that kind of stuff yeah you
for whatever you do anyway yeah
primal bells zombie bells and legend
bells those are the ones cool jump ropes
on there too by the way
another fitness stuff interesting
fitness stuff and again the kettlebells
I recommend the kettlebells but like me
start light don't swing in and get your
shin don't like that yeah Jack yourself
up yeah there's some technique involved
yeah and you don't recognize the
momentum of swinging a kettlebell is a
real thing yeah and then it only weighs
35 pounds in your case when you swing it
to the top of and then you have to stop
that thing it's not waiting 2535 pounds
anymore it's got momentum yeah and then
when you Scott centrifugal force yes so
you know the one where it's like a
regular snipe I guess it's not a snatch
but to clean yeah I know you go up and
it's yeah yeah because the rack position
so even that I've seen it done so I'm
like oh I can do that I'll just use it
light but I'm doing it wrong I'm like
flipping it flipping it up where it
lands on the back of my wrist and then
it like pulls my shoulder back I'm like
how do they do this that's like I just
gotta use but then I looked it up on
YouTube the actual technique and then
I'm like okay you know I'm gonna chip my
tooth the other day with two front
squats with the kettlebell okay yeah I
don't know I just like lifted it up
really hard because I was going from the
pic in it from the floor tech up to the
to the position to start squatting and I
like did it so hard that I hit my
on tooth yeah you idiot yeah rabbit
thing yeah they can mean Dean just be
careful that's the point anyway on accom
slash Jocko check them out those are
cool ones they have the regular ones too
but I don't know man once you have the
design when you can't go back my opinion
not that I have any basis for comparison
because I've never had the normal ones
but I've seen them in other gyms used
them before and it's not the same my
opinion also if you want to get this
book the diary of Nepal Nepali an ik
foot soldier there you go or any books
that chocolate talks about or writes
author by the way we have direct links
to all these books per episode on our
website chocolate caste calm the books
the books section it's books from
episodes I think that's what it's called
anyway go on there click through there
not only is it organized you can find
the correct book that you're looking for
it supports the podcast or if you're
doing any other shopping that day or
that moment and whatever boom carry on
good way to support also subscribe to
the podcast on itunes google play
stitcher all these podcasting providing
platforms and youtube by the way youtube
on top of the video version of this
podcast as we all know we have little
excerpts that you can share so you don't
have to share the whole thing or it's
just more of a chance someone's gonna
listen to what you share what else
should we put on youtube what else i
think i she put stuff on youtube because
i think i could do it more frequently
than you well actually maybe not because
i do it three times a week if you count
the podcast really yeah really
right I've gotten into a good routine
Monday Wednesday Friday I'll look into
that for the most part okay I still
think maybe I should do something I
won't do something like what can you do
live on YouTube yes I do that yeah I
don't know I've never done it before but
Joe Rogan does it all the time like yeah
YouTube live stuff nonetheless subscribe
to the YouTube there's some I also
deleted scenes that's what put on there
maybe not as often but if you want to
see some behind the
curtain right that's person behind the
scenes you want to hear miss swear
apparently yeah I used to bunch of
skinny knees
yeah podcast sure I was wearing it
earlier today pre recording today as
well I forgot what you're talking about
but it's something that made me feel the
urge to swear something in motion
what was it talking about he things
you'll have to check deleted see ya ex
ex or r-rated sure not x-rated
thankfully that's like nudity and
whatnot and whatnot sure I'll be honored
yeah no no not also so yeah that's
YouTube YouTube subscribe if you haven't
already if you're into YouTube saying
that's a good way to support also jock
wise the store it's called Jacko's store
go to jaakko store calm makes sense
right that's where you can get shirts
are shirts you know the podcast shirts
discipling let's read them all this
stuff some cool ones on there
look at those and if you want something
get something we also have women's stuff
on there for the lady troopers out there
mmm or the guys you know your wife
daughter sister mom boom
Dave Burke hit me up he was like my wife
on some shirts mm-hmm I said you got a
check no worries she's in the game yep
some patches on their hoodies the
heavier hoodies I got them their lives
they're not life right now but what are
you doing everyone but we live this week
100% okay with that okay good I'm
hesitant heavy New England for New
England people yes Minnesota right there
for a Minnesota Chicago yep Michigan all
them Michigan Canada because when you're
up there you sometimes you just wear
that just that's what you wear yeah
that's all I used to wear when I was a
kid yeah from like November until March
just the heavy hoodie that's it get some
can't really not the hoodie that you
made last year the kauai version that's
not even the koi Regent it's like the
island
like the kids it's not even SoCal
version that thing was too light for
SoCal so now summer a I guess maybe yeah
baby yeah looking forward to heavy yeah
he's good um yeah so yeah hoodies on
their other stuff check it out chuckles
doors calm that's a good way to support
hats too right you're supposed to eat me
hats yeah but yeah that's it for the
people no but I need hats too yeah
there's some hats on there oh you you
need hats go to jockle store okay also
psychological psychological warfare a
good way to support yourself good way to
help yourself good way to spot yourself
on your journey I'm going back to
journey the same journey enough on your
journey slash campaign against weakness
like you know you're on the program now
you're waking up early now you're
working I got a workout program five
days I don't know you know it's
interesting you use the word program
this is interesting
Lafe and the Delta platoon commander
Seth stone back in the day Danny like
asked me for like what I did for
workouts yeah and I wrote out my
workouts and it's actually loosely there
in there in the discipline equals
freedom Field Manual but when I gave it
to him it just said at the top of the
thing it said the program yeah yeah
actually I really like that expression
and I think it's like one of those
things you know how you always say
discipline will not allow that
yeah I'll say I'm on the program yeah
program exactly right so if you're on
the program which really life is you
should be on the program really if
you're not you're just like what you're
like short term you're not on the front
and we know that yeah yeah it's bad and
sometimes you don't even realize that
you're not on the program I think that's
the problem
you don't even realize you're not on the
program yeah well have you never been on
the program then know that you're not on
it yeah what what does JP call it like
in unconsciously calm incompetent or
something like that you know yes
all the things all the psychological
state in learning I don't know either
way if you don't know you're not on the
program you don't even know what you
don't know kind of thing that kind of
thing anyway back to the program if
you're on the program but you experience
those days those moments of weakness and
you want chocolate to get you through
them help you through them like a little
spot you're not gonna take over but as a
spot you listen to psychological warfare
for your moment of weakness and it goes
by situation right waking up there's
like waking up one there's a missing
workout one is procrastination one
they're all these what it is this in
it's an album with tracks each track is
for each weakness you may or may not
come across that's good yeah so as we
got into and and that a lot of people
like that album yeah and so when
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
was being created sure the the normal
option is you publish books on
audible.com and then they put together
the book with chapters that you can
listen to through the audible app it's
very confined to that yeah so for the
Field Manual III the way the field nanos
written it's not written like a book
it's more like an album yeah that you'd
need to use with tracks so any ways to
make a long story short we are gonna
make another psychological warfare album
but in the meantime we put out
discipline equals freedom field manual
which is the book that just came out and
if you're looking for an audible version
of that you have to go to iTunes Amazon
music Google Play everywhere everywhere
that they sell mp3 tracks albums with
tracks and that's where you can get
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
audio version and that that one makes a
lot more sense though with with it this
way oh for sure because it is like a
manual you know like yeah but yeah and
the thought was I didn't want to put it
on an audible book the audible form
because then people can't put it on
their alarm clock they can't they can't
just jump through it and listen that
track they can't put it into their
playlist while they're working out yeah
so therefore not use not not good that
is youth yeah so I know we're not gonna
sell as many because when it's linked
right there on the website on Amazon
people can click right to it so we're
not gonna sell as many but it's better
anyway it doesn't matter either I'd
rather put out good product yeah that's
my concern and especially when you're
referring to it because that's really
what a manual their money audible no coz
think of the link would be right there
you know cuz what's okay on Amazon it
says format for the book you know
hardcover and then kindle kindle and
then audible touch mine doesn't have
that so people can't click on it and
they ask me they've been asking me on
Twitter
when's the audible color are you gonna
do an audible one I just have to respond
to everyone it's on bah-bah-bah
gotcha so again we're just I'm more
concerned that people that have it can
utilize it properly yeah and for sure I
do but not as much I use Kindle that's
where the actual like reading part of it
it's a lobster but the this with the
tracks hmm it is better because when you
want to refer to you know like it's like
okay I want to go to the martial arts
part you know all this these other parts
when you want to refer to it it's good
of me then I'm thinking back with the
audible format it's gonna be harder to
be like okay and find it you you're not
gonna enjoy doing that exactly yes it is
good to you know listen to if you want
to listen to one whole person yeah
exactly yeah hit it up yeah but it does
make more sense when you think about the
whole scope yeah the discipline Field
Manual so if yeah if you get the
opportunity to tell people that and tell
them because I can't tell everyone I
tried yeah but where you can find it
here's here's the thing ultimately it's
not hard to get I mean it's no it's not
hard to get it off not on the same spot
where you'd expect it and people expect
to find things where they expect to find
things yeah and so we've thrown him a
curveball a little you know but it's
it's like I said to produce something
that would be less usable
my people in the manner that they want
to use it or make it a little bit harder
to find like I said maybe not as many
people can buy it because they won't
find it I don't care
I'd rather have the people that really
want it get to use it the way I want to
use it that's serve that's how I run
slowest curve ball in the history of
curve ball yeah here get it on yeah here
you have to do an extra click you'd be
surprised how many people asked on
social media when it where when it's
coming out all right in the audio format
yeah that does make sense though
especially if you're used to listening
for audio books then you're like okay I
want to do the book right now where's
the audio it's about Lee makes an
audible curveball yeah loser that is a
curveball that's true hey while you're
on Amazon also you can get chocolate
white tea which tastes good and will
guarantee you a deadlift of eight
thousand pounds some other books you'd
get on there away the warrior kid that's
for kids that want to get after it or
even if you want your kid to get after
it you want to be smarter stronger
better you want to eat healthier get him
that book awesome feedback on that book
which is some of my favorite feedback is
pictures of kids reading away the
warrior kid doing pull-ups doing
pull-ups and doing jiu-jitsu yeah and
doing flashcards and their little book
reports I like seeing the book reports
like when you do a book report when
you're seven years old it's kind of a
big deal it's like you're getting
published for the first time as an
author you're like hey I wrote this this
is my assessment of the book weigh the
warrior kid probably the most important
thing I've ever been written check it
out and I also do a picture yeah you
don't I mean that's Uncle Jake right
there you can't hardly tell because
doesn't look anything like him but it's
supposed to go Jake Art's not my thing
over here but yeah I like seeing those
little things up we got the book extreme
ownership written by myself and my
brother Leif Babin and it is about
combat leadership
this woman's freedom Field Manual yes
the book that just came out and thanks
everyone for getting it for spreading
the word for I like a bunch of people
have put on stacks they're getting it
not just for them because they're on the
path they're on the program okay they
want to get their friends on the program
they want to get there but work person
they want to get their kid on the
program father son saw that one
yesterday on social media
father son boom boom two copies getting
on the program so that's awesome and
appreciate it oh there's some in there's
some funny reviews I got I'll have to
read some of the review some of the
Amazon reviews some of them some of them
are awesome there's a 1i I should pull
it out but um there's some awesome
reviews so if you want to write a review
you can do that it's a work of art
really I mean to look at it I think it
looks pretty cool it's pretty there's no
other books that really look like that
not that I know so that's that and like
I said the the audio version is on mp3
Google Play iTunes Amazon music and all
that if you need leadership support for
your team or your business then you can
higher echelon front which is our
leadership and management consulting
company it's me Lafe babban JP Danelle
Dave Burke email info - L'Enfant dot-com
and if you kind of liked hanging out
with us on this podcast and you want to
maybe cruise with us some more you can
find us on the interwebs Twitter
Instagram and fishable haha EKKO is at
Echo Charles and I am at Jocko willing
and again thanks to all of you out there
in uniform on the front lines like Jacob
Walter in the dirt and
filth and the discomfort and the danger
out there holding the line thank you all
for what you do to the police and law
enforcement and firefighters and medical
emergency technicians and the rest the
first responders thank you for keeping
us safe here at home to the teachers out
there that are teaching our kids
teaching those young troublemakers like
I was putting them on the right path
teaching them that discipline equals
freedom thank you for doing what you do
and the rest of you that are out there
doing your job and doing it to the best
of your ability making life better for
yourself your family your community our
country and the world
thanks for grinding and grappling and
striving and scratching and continuing
day after day after day to get out there
and get after it
so until next time this is echo and
Jocko out
you